et puis pendant cette période d'après
élections parle aussi beaucoup vous le
savez des radios libres monsieur georges
fillioud avait une longue déclaration
cette semaine à ce propos et jeudi sur
la trentaine d'antennes de midi alors
qu'elle gens du crible monsieur claude
estier évoqué lui aussi l'éventuelle
libéralisation de la loi en ce domaine
et bien justement les responsables des
radios libres vont se rencontrer de ma
part ils entendent définir l'opposition
vis-à-vis de ce futur gouvernement
patrick estève et jacques van ga verts
ont rencontré la nuit dernière les
animateurs de l'une de ces radios lee
récemment en recherchant une station de
radio en mode ia ce une fréquence vais
peut-être entendu cet indicatif bizarre
c'est celui de radio cité future île
radio pirate qui a commencé à émettre
dimanche dernier à 20h dès les premiers
résultats des élections radio cité
future c'est la radio du journal le
monde qui occupe avec cet indicatif la
fréquence 96
en fait toutes les radios libres
attendent beaucoup du changement de
président françois mitterrand lui-même
est encore inculpé pour émirates la fin
du monopole des ondes commencerais par
éviter aux animateurs de ces radios
libres
les incessants déménagement des
installations nécessaires pour déjouer
les plans de la police
1 2 1 2 3 paris bordeaux le mans
cependant depuis longtemps mais
j'entends les autres aussi bas c'est
normal
d'accord vous écoutez radio vertes dansa
bonsoir vous êtes à l'écouté de radio
verte sur 99 mégahertz comme tous les
joueurs il est 22h30 vous vous entendez
donc radio vers quelle station ni
interdite ni autorisé ce soir un
programme spécial rock avec café mozart
café mozart et un de leurs meilleurs
morceaux massacre longtemps
roulez jeunesse
il prend pour faire une radio voyez pas
besoin d'énormément de matériel pour
acquis mélangeur eu une ou deux platines
quelques micros des casques est
évidemment un émetteur d'un émetteur
italiens comme on voit sur la carte
un buffet 350 watts c'est à dire que dit
couvrent largement tout paris sans
problème surtout place ce soit on est
bien placés 1 et donc on couvre la
région parisienne sans aucun problème
techniquement maîtres en modulation de
fréquence nécessite peu de matériel donc
peu d'argent un émetteur de 10 watts par
exemple suffit pour couvrir un ou deux
arrondissements de paris et ce type
d'émetteurs ne coûtent que 1000 francs
royaume s'oppose à la multiplication des
radios libres
seul problème technique le nombre de
longueurs d'onde disponibles on peut
facilement mettre 40 à 50 stations même
peut-être plus il ya de la place
vraiment pour tout le monde
c'est pas la multiplicité des taxes 27 à
craindre c'est la politisation
anarchique de stations à mon avis plus
ou moins commercial et émettant les du
matériel qui sont pas conformes à des
normes fixe fixé mais une quarantaine de
radio x n'est pas de former dans le
problème n'est plus radios commerciales
bah on ya pensé depuis 1978 on a discuté
avec le ps fait dessus et nous on pense
qu'en limitant la publicité à 5 minutes
par heure en limitant la puissance on
peut empêcher des grosses stations
commerciales avec d'écraser les petites
cela dit au niveau de l'association
glauque elle en a qu'on a fait à dessus
qui s'appelle l'association pour la
libération des ondes
on a été contacté par des très gros
hebdomadaires et des très grands
quotidiens qui veulent se lancer dans la
radio après l'arrivée de huit rangs et
c'est vrai qu'on se pose ensemble de
questions est ce qu'on les aide comme
ans et est ce qu'on met des conditions à
cette aide pendant quatre ans na et la
police ont eu le brouillage convoqué
procès et là il semblerait que on va
être au moins tolérées et j'espère un
peu autorisé en tout cas hier soir
encore radio verte étaient brouillés
après seulement trente minutes
d'émission
quand je vous rappelle tout de même mais
je le rappelle surtout aux amateurs le
monopole de divisions existent toujours
en france 2 par une loi votée par le
parlement
les radios libres sont donc toujours et
encore interdite